Для батьків рано чи пізно настає етап,
коли їхня дитина повинна обрати професію,
а потім вступити в університет або заклад професійної освіти
Зрозуміти логіку, за якою сучасний підліток обирає собі фах,
нам допоможе теорія поколінь
Ми маємо справу з поколінням Z
Яке воно та які його цінності? Отже,
сучасна молодь звикла до миттєвого
доступу до інформації та швидкого сервісу
вона цінує свободу та індивідуальність
швидко засвоює інформацію, але не може
довго концентруватися на чомусь одному
Для ефективної розмови з підлітком
спробуйте використати такі методи:
дозволяйте йому бути собою
слухайте і приймайте до уваги його думки
підтримуйте у навчанні, у нових захопленнях, у моменти помилок
хваліть та цікавтеся його інтересами
У сучасної молоді формальна освіта не є цінністю
Для них цінність – саморозвиток, самореалізація та навчання
Молодь шукає цікавих професій, де є можливість реалізувати свої вміння
Будьте готові, що ваші погляди на майбутнє можуть відрізнятися
Наприклад, син чи дочка оберуть для себе професію будівельника,
а ви бачите її чи його економістом
Немає більшого задоволення, ніж займатися улюбленою справою
І цього заслуговує кожен
Не бійтесь довіряти своїм дітям, і нехай
вони перетворять талант на справжню професію